President Trump will meet with Saudi
Crown Prince Mohammed bin Salman next
week at the White House the crown prince
is making unprecedented changes within
Saudi Arabia and a large focus is on the
role of women in society the Kingdom is
the last country that denies women the
freedom to drive but that won't be for
long we recently visited Saudi Arabia
for this Sunday's 60 minutes and spoke
with the Crown Prince it is the first
u.s. television interview with a Saudi
leader since 2005 and we went to the
world's largest all-female university in
Riyadh where Saudi women are test
driving their freedom you're responsible
for saving people's lives yes and you
can't drive doctor rubra al-zuhari is
studying to become a surgeon she's also
studying for her driver's license
this will also decrease some of the
costs out of paying on taxis on a driver
this will help me be independent she's
one of the women paving the way at the
driving school at Princess Noor
University Saudi Arabia's first driving
school for women this is a small change
but it's a significant impact on our
society
what do the men think they're very
significantly positive that's why it's
the right timing back in 2011 and 2013
there was a negative reaction what's
changed the whole society is changing
starting in June women above the age of
18 will no longer have to rely on
drivers or male relatives to get around
wearing abayas traditional garments they
wear in public
Saudi women are learning to drive at
facilities like this you're gonna give
me a drive yeah like the other
instructors dr. Dima alsa khat has a
driver's license from living abroad hers
is from the state of Virginia so you've
never driven in Saudi Arabia except here
at the school yeah
Crown Prince Mohammed bin Salman lifted
the driving ban in part to boost women's
participation in the workforce
i can'twe themselves to be part of it as
the economy diversifies away from oil
what's been the hardest thing to learn
we have two obstacles facing women here
in our country transportation and
childcare and we try from this school to
solve these two problems those solutions
include a nursery and a traffic village
for older children the lesson that it's
normal for girls to drive you're
establishing a new culture yes much has
changed for Saudi women who are entering
new professions and graduating from
universities in record numbers Princess
Rima Ben Ben dar al saud is championing
women's rights and she says driving is
part of a bigger vision to envisage
change you actually have to have a sense
of where you'd like to go
we would like women to have the
opportunity for mobility for decision
making and for social integration today
mobility June is going to be pretty much
resolved every and any woman will tell
you I want more and I want it right now
the issue is right now for me is
tomorrow for somebody else so how do I
make sure we all get to where we need to
go together
that's actually a more difficult
conversation than you would actually
believe driving is just a quick win it's
not everything and it's progress the
trajectory now is just going forward and
not backwards you are witnessing history
part of it we're the ones that are gonna
tell our grandkids about it that we live
through this you know I was so impressed
by by the women who have advanced
degrees they're 60% of university
graduates and yet they make up only 10%
of the workforce you can't change the
economy in Saudi Arabia without changing
the culture and the first step in
changing the culture is changing the
role of women it's such a young
population to like that yes I like that
she said what the most difficult thing
was the curves I was thinking parallel
parking a lot of space how are you gonna
react to them driving well interesting
one young woman that I spoke with said
that her dad was going to start making
her drive him around now though I think
they're also pleased by the freedom
because many times their schedules they
have to drive there why
our daughters to a doctor appointment
they have to drive them to school so it
does free up their time as well do they
get to practice other than simulators
because you know that's great but you
really got to get on the road with other
cars yes you saw those white cars that
we yeah yeah so that they can take on
the road oh yeah but the Saudis have
lined up everything yeah those are nice
test cars - and we're gonna feature
previews of our interview with Saudi
Crown Prince Mohammed bin Salman
tomorrow and Friday
right here on CBS this morning and you
can see our full report Sunday night on
60 minutes it will air in two parts
there's a lot of news if I may say so
myself it airs at 7 6 central right here
on CBS and you may say so yourself can't
wait to see it